let's go next to our caller from the
nine five one area code caller from nine
five one where are you calling from
what's your name this is me that is
indeed you
oh hi my name is Billy I'm from
California
hey Billy what's going to have I have
two questions and Billy we're not honest
and I'm try to go in our way but I can't
imagine we'd be on speakerphone right
now
no we're not there's a fan in the
building I'm in can you hear that is
that what you're hearing I don't know it
just sounded like you got very far for a
second there it sounded like what what's
your question Billy we're ready for it
okay sorry um the first question is a
co-worker mentioned that if we removed
minimum wage like things would be better
as a nation I thought because something
about wars economic artificial floors
are bad it prevents people from
negotiating truth value it increases
unemployment that kind of thing listen
all of those arguments did those strike
you as good arguments no so that's part
of where I'm kissed to me something
about it seemed kind of fishy but I have
co-workers you okay some of this is
sounding like it makes sense and I don't
actually know anything about economics
so I figured hey I might that's gonna
dope who does yeah so the first thing I
would do is go to google and type in
debunking minimum wage price floor okay
and you will find a way wealth of
information about that it is true that
in a classical economics framework you
can put a very convincing looking graph
together which will make it appear as
though that is the effect of a price
floor the reality is we are almost at
full employment we continue to be almost
at full employment even in places that
have eleven twelve and fifteen dollar
minimum wages and what you have to
understand is that there is a very
particular inset well some people maybe
are acting
good faith but there is a very
particular bad faith incentive to make
these arguments by people who just don't
want businesses regulated and they want
businesses to be able to pay three four
five dollars an hour and the fact that
you can have such an unequal and
problematic economy that people would be
willing to work for three or four
dollars an hour doesn't mean that it's
the right thing to do or what we should
be doing and that's the important thing
yes if you remove the minimum wage you
will see companies paying less and
people accepting it and being willing to
accept that but the long-term
implications of that are not good the
the long-term implications of that on
crime are not good the long-term
implications of that on government
benefits spending and welfare programs
aren't good so you need to zoom out in
order to really understand the context
of those talking points okay and then my
other question was about health care the
one argument that was made is that
because we have health and insurance it
allows companies to charge us really
high prices and if we didn't have like a
health insurance base and instead people
paid like out of pocket themselves it
would drive prices down or something
because these companies would still have
to sell their products to people and if
they can work less or something it would
drive prices down yep that's a total
free market solution and that might work
when there when demand is not as
inelastic as it is in health care but
health care is different than health
care should not be treated as a normal
market because basically if you don't
need a hip replacement you don't care
whether a hip replacement costs a dollar
or a thousand dollars or a hundred
thousand dollars if you do need a hip
replacement you're in a relatively small
group right it's still not everybody
needs hip replacements and all of a
sudden what it costs has no impact
whatsoever on how badly you need that
hip replacement and this is the reason
why those sort of free-market laser fare
ideas
we shouldn't even be in the picture when
we're talking about health care and most
Western developed countries have already
figured that out um maybe I didn't quite
communicate what I'm trying to ask
correctly it's the idea is like if
people can't afford in insulin at the
current price wouldn't health care
industries or something lower the price
and that the only reason they can get
away with charging like a high price is
because insurance companies can pay it
no that's not that's not the only reason
and this is related to multiple
different levels that we've we've
analyzed in detail and this includes the
fact that there are yes insurance
companies do not cert n'r AIT's for
products and in order to get a certain
reimbursement rate that causes an
incentive to make the sticker prices
higher and higher but it's it's far more
complicated than this and we've got a
couple videos on it that I would I would
encourage you to check out no problem
thank you for your time all right
appreciate the call